[Musique]
si ceux ci
veulent par la force
réduire les positions et coupé les
communications
des alliés à berlin
les alliés doivent par la force
maintenir leur position et maintenir
leur communication
assurément de fil en aiguille comme on
dit et si tout cela fait multiplier les
actes hostiles des soviets acte
auxquelles il faudrait répondre
on pourrait en venir
à la guerre générale
mais alors
c'est que les soviets il aurait
délibérément voulue
et dans ce cas tout recul préalable de
l'occident
n'aurait servi qu'à l'affaiblir et à le
diviser
et sans empêcher l'échéance
un certain point de menaces de la part
d'un impérialisme ambitieux
tout recul
a pour effet de surexcités l'agresseur
de le pousser à redoubler sa pression
et finalement
facilite est apte son assaut
au total
actuellement
les puissances occidentales
n'ont pas de meilleur moyen de servir la
paix du monde
que le rester droite et ferme
est ce que ça veut dire que pour
toujours
les deux camps devront s'opposer
ce n'est pas du tout ce que pense la
france
parce que ce serait vraiment très bête
et que ce serait vraiment très cher
si le conflit mondial doit éclater
alors
le progrès mécanique moderne
aura abouti à la mort
sinon c'est la paix qu'il faut tenter de
faire
[Musique]